this ground covers two big trees and
everything in between
including vegetables rooftop farms are
about ten percent of the work that we do
the pilots need stop but it is far away
we have designed to build over the past
nine years and I'm thrilled to be here
thank you very much Patti when Martin
recruited in the end of another package
deal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so absolutely and I thought I had come
full circle and reentered when we
entered the food industry and I
vegetables in this is a customer's up
there in the habitat creation the air
filtration and I talk about how they
hold who's wise was a plant and I
remember the I knew of the day
and I was driving to work and I was so
excited it finally hit me and I fell
that's going to be a little celebrity
absolutely recognized new academic
Street Marcus leeeeee office literally
nobody would look at the article and all
the things I said whoa
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and so I wonder I wonder why I have I
have about 15 to 20 slides and it does a
great job of answering these questions
has some great interviews and if I try
to get there and play it for you but if
we don't get there
[Music]
this is Marcus warrants and Marco Soros
was the head chef of the vegetation
enhancing plastic which was a new
restaurant started by three men from the
construction industry so that no idea
about how to run a restaurant but they
did hire Marco who was a passionate chef
and you believe in trying to get the
freshest ingredients very proud of what
is cooking and agree that who was better
than fresh ingredients and he heard
about Eagle Street rooftop farm which
was one of the first roof hot part of
the US and Brooklyn and one night all
the stars align faculty that with Hank
my business partner without some kind of
event for at a bar and he was introduced
to work and why I was so excited to meet
a company that actually build these this
is our first rooftop farm so we don't
bring Bruce part of the type of a green
room and he definitely pursued the
owners until they finally that yes in
the region hired us to build a roof
after their restaurant and suddenly my
business partner I recovered readers
right middle of the urban dagonet which
is definitely incredibly exciting and
unexpected developments inside our
company this was one of our first
projects and you're so concerned about
the complexity of the structural
engineer the waterproofing the Apple III
waterproof to make sure there are any
leaks we were concerned about knox
materials knowing that we're going to be
growing edibles out there and we didn't
think too much about building those and
we didn't even think about applying for
permanent which because we didn't think
[Music]
someone fearless and
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
spring of the ceilings and tools on the
shot goes in there are the hardest
[Music]
it's not beautiful absolutely transform
that space we had architectural if I
rotate this great secret out of you guys
take pictures during the sunrise to give
it that nice folding low and this
project is what led to our multiple
projects which is what for the southern
map I have to introduce any Novak event
planner to require the founding team of
Eagle streets with hot fires anybody
heard of Eagle streets one person two
people are great in turn it's incredibly
exciting project go back in 2009 the
building owners financed the building
the New York City Greenwood company cut
good grade and they got the help of any
event in apologia to do to build this
roof incredibly successful project
enacted a generous and incredible amount
of excitement of the chef who hired us
but they because they were because it
was financed by the building owner the
they weren't too big have a lot of
little thing to experience what they
were going on there how to distribute
the food and they slowly started
focusing their efforts on educational
programming to do what they're told me
is when they brought kids are there near
city would never been outside the
combined intensity I've never actually
seen vegetables growing and it's never
just always took for granted where their
food came from and to go out on a roof
and actually see vegetables growing out
of the ground as I don't think for that
and so that they really great
educational activity there and
[Music]
at the end of the year they have scale
this is a full inner roof the whole
foods was less than after that size but
he also was able to take advantage of
opportunity burn this this rooftop farm
gave people the chance to farm
never had that chance for anywhere near
to the area and so people were happy to
do this for free and they in fact we
were able to get a team of mighty
river's to the farm and their crosstown
and they also have a great market a lot
of farmers markets that they sell
distribute to local food and they'll
have a violent CSA program but then I
realized that that itself just revenue
from selling vegetables still wasn't
enough to helping me try but they really
had more value than just the produce is
up and what they had was incredible
States and this picture is on Google
heading
but I think this fiction itself might
answer the question why grows vegetables
on a roof and it's the space when you're
in the city and in New York especially
you're really stuck inside alive and
there's not a lot of open air and fresh
air to enjoy the environment and a bear
group is a fairly
unhospitable place a black we get 160
degrees in this summer and it's just not
a comfortable place to sit and eat but
when you put that up our minds at any
air temperature down to a much more
hospitable level and it creates this
beautiful open air or an oasis which you
don't have very much of in cities and as
our cities grow and they are all
projected to double in the next couple
of decades all those buildings are
taking up all the green open states and
so what's left is a lot of group space
and how can you transform that through
space and and make it into a place to
enjoy like this and they're able to sell
these tickets these mental
that food the table dinner if this is
three or four years ago he told me
they're silent see for $75 apiece so
this is a big revenue channel for them
that help them become profitable and the
other really magical thing about open
air farm in a city weather isn't much
open airy space and they also elevated
to the street level and that makes a
world of a difference the pedestrians
the car they had a lot of really strong
rush energy and it's stressful and to go
up a few stories to escape that street
level energy it is really create a nice
peaceful Oasis up there so I can add
this mediation up on that slide but I
still have 25 minutes they also do they
also do more than just those food table
events a at most weddings of their
that's what
they have funding from the Department of
Environmental Protection because it's a
way to manage stormwater which is kind
of nice pensive for cities to do
especially when it's very hard to build
an infrastructure under the streets to
manage on the stormwater they also
obviously have value-added products like
this hot sauce that they can make much
more money summer that's awesome and
they can adapt everything sucks whatever
I don't have a pair of t-shirts they
make a lot of money selling t-shirts so
they are really made was able to make
some money rooftop farming but it wasn't
just telling that vegetables themselves
it was really selling that the brand and
the space they created this project that
this is probably the most impressive my
high my favorite level for department of
business sense is astounded by
hey who's Lebanese where farming is very
personal to hear me because it's very
hard to farm in Lebanon and he told me
that cute understands the importance of
keeping populations and his mission is
to to feed the population clean city
centers whether it isn't much apartment
so he was also a businessman wonderful
for any business model to be sustainable
it has to be financially sustainable so
when he's able to do here with this
greenhouse that that chance to network
arrange is grown twelve months out of
the year and he uses hydroponics inside
that big mouth and Hypertime field much
more produce that that soil does and he
has
vegetables and was handing out these
made us to prove that type of food
actually tastes good and it did such a
generic very sweet but we're hammer
Mohammed rooftop farming is about food
security and providing big city centers
this is the fossa Medical Center which
is a rooftop partly built in boxes and
they they they're they're not selling
these vegetables they are paying for
today for the insemination got a founder
attending auction to pay for the entire
process in stock and they hired farmer
to do all the farming and they give all
the produce to their low-income patients
it's part of a new method for doing
business or about holistic healing and
Timisoara
good healing it was healthy diets and so
there Boston Medical Center is trying to
bring that into their their equation
working with patients and giving them
healthy food as part of the healing
process the blossom Medical Center was
designed this Beach done what we did at
Fenway Park and this is family farms
which is what I finally built back in
2015 we were we were ready on opening
day which was able thirteen at that day
and a week before theirs
to get the vegetables time but they
their original interesting rooftop
farming was to show their sustainability
that we first reach out to us they said
eight is a great way to show our fans
that we care about the environment and
then Linda Henry
she the only one that's right she is the
other way
Johnny and she got she is a urban
agricultural supporter and she wanted to
grow vegetables somewhere at Fenway Park
and she heard up
we were working either originally to
make this one of those sedum extensive
more about stormwater management and she
said you can't even see them
let's put food on Bethany Kenny and she
her husband is ready yvm the European
Socrates
[Music]
Liverpool Socrates or the farm and apart
it was so it successful that here too
they extended yet see the difference
there that was 2015 and that was 2016
and what they realized they that farm
really transformed that states and
needed a beautiful shapes that people
wanted to be out enjoying so they cared
the second one that was occupied on this
first one is a wheelchair accessible so
technically the
but they wanted to allow the public to
go out there to enjoy that open-air
urban oasis and they miss their
closeness be in number one secrets spot
in Boston and whatever magical space of
who can be late the city of beautiful
views before we stop it that you can see
those plants really transfer on that
stage like 100 United States and you can
see there I'm afraid that's where all
the fans go the seating is on the farm
and you can see the lights here today
but these are on the losing section
standards are so you can see a lot of
people have access to that vegetables
black underutilized water food membrane
and interestingly they do this is
incredible to me to give daily tours
seven days a week every hour limit of 50
people per tour every tourist sold out
they do it 365 days a year
and the bending part the number one sets
stop on a tour people come out they're
not expecting to see a vegetable there's
just jaw-dropping
when you're not expecting to see see
this and to see it and I think I think
it leaves little for exploration and
discovery and for seen things that
you're not expected to see and I think
that people really are impressed by that
people are attracted
example of that I would repeat remiss
not to talk about city grubbers that's
just a nickname from the left she bones
and running speed runners and that's why
people on the right he's the executive
chef at seven o'clock this would not
work without those two company without
those two organizations is incredibly
hard though it takes commitment
impatience and green city growers
defecating parties that do all that
farming without them this wouldn't be
successful and then Ronnie will plays a
critical role because he had the
challenge of actually cooking this food
and he is at the mercy of the weather
the harvest and he has to adjust menu to
whatever it is in season
being an artisan and that requires them
to be creative and flexible and you know
you can't just go in and do the same
thing
all day but that just keeps of that
Patrick because he wouldn't told me he
wouldn't want to go into the kitchen the
same thing ever said that was born and
this farm it really excites it's
passionate to be able to use his
creativity and to work with the food
that is being harvested in public in
every time we just talks about food and
ingredients and what you can do with all
these different vegetables and it's
doubly challenging for him not only does
he have to juggle the season in the
harvest but he also has a packed
schedule and when the team is on the
road and yet the apartment is tough for
him to take advantage of whether it's
being harvested
[Music]
I'm really glad that I came to be on my
vacation because this videos we're
showing you guys if you didn't set this
up
yeah
[Music]
what that looks like this
and looking around being here
[Music]
people live
but all of unused space in the city
department rooftops that actually
uncovered causes environmental problems
so you cover it you're going awesome
food welcome is fantasy play live
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
away
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
earth
[Music]
that overs are designed for their
regular extra collectivization
particularly very visitors that whole
process might agree with networking
Huckabee's arrangement cetera
one of our operation it's been
[Music]
represents beautifying neighborhoods
making you need more fiber and there are
[Music]
[Music]
to the community through CSS
Sanderson sort
we party I had this relationship so when
we have Excel they were well aware Jimmy
wanting to buy it
that he thinks about starting a business
community had a lot of relationships
[Music]
I didn't even initially Edition organics
and ran out of 49 if you all work past
the volunteers from the Calvin
watch everything that's involved in
getting the products market
what we do in New Mexico coolers
depending on the delivery
we will attract the front backs of our
fight
both of the girls immediately tended to
get
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
more than
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu